good evening welcome to alternative
views we have with us tonight Dave
Dellinger who's been described as
America's most durable radical as ken
carpenter indicated in the discussion
who will also be with us today Dave has
been active for four decades in the
movements for peace and social justice
in America today thanks for coming today
we're very glad to have you
let's begin by discussing your origins
in the peace movement what led you to
resist the draft in World War two I was
your basic pacifist principles there
well actually it began with the
depression I grew up in a suburb of
Boston my father was chairman of the
Republican Town Committee and at a
certain point there was the stock market
crash when I was in a freshman I think
in high school and then all of a sudden
according to the philosophy of
republicanism and the kind of philosophy
that Ronald Reagan symbolizes today when
the unemployment rolls went up from 1
million to 3 million to 6 million I was
led to believe that maybe 5 million
people had suddenly become lazy and
didn't want to work and you know because
there were all these jobs available but
they were too fussy or what have you
and this I think was my introduction to
radicalism by the way by radical I mean
going to the roots count you know that's
a Latin word radix radicals roots and
not just putting a band-aid on when
there's a deep wound or taking aspirin
for cancer and treating the society the
same way but there was also in the 30s a
very strong connected with the social
justice movement in the movement on
behalf of the people who were suddenly
thrown out of work or were being evicted
from their homes for non-payment of rent
or mortgages or whatever it was there
was a strong anti-war movement and
that's one reason I appreciated not the
so-called you know the praise but well
that Ken carpenter dried off that I
identified with or interested in social
justice and economic justice as well as
anti-war and I think it's wrong to
separate them but in the 30s they
weren't separated because in the
depression there was also a lot of
exposure about
the arms merchants the merchants of
death Woodrow Wilson had said in a
speech that is there any man woman or
child in America or any child who does
not know that this was an industrial and
commercial war relating to a World War
one but also in the course of pursuing
that I became acquainted largely through
Gandhi and India who was leading a
massive militant nonviolent struggle for
the independence of his country from the
British Empire in the methods of
non-violence so putting all of those
things together I came to believe that
human problems would not be solved
first of all unless you linked them all
and realized that there was some kind of
political and human attitude that joined
economics and war and daily life but
secondly that we wouldn't really be
posing an alternative to society's ways
of dealing things unless we developed
nonviolent methods but not just methods
of like I'm not going to be violent that
I'm going to be a pacifist and but I
don't care if of these black people you
know have a higher rate of unemployment
and a higher incidence of infant
mortality and all the rest but but
linking them together and actually I
went to prison the first time and had
served the year in a day was out of
prison before Pearl Harbor was attacked
of course now we know and and as a
matter of fact I have to say that I knew
at the time that the United States had
broken the Japanese code that they had
decided they had already as a matter of
fact the United States has already been
sinking Japanese ships in the Pacific
and they had decided on more but they
maneuvered to try to make Japan make a
kind of apparently sneak attack and am i
saying that the Japan didn't try a sneak
attack to but to try something which
would turn the country finally against
American non-involvement against against
America's refusal to think that the way
to get rid of fascism and Empire in the
world was was to solve it with bombs and
guns and
all the rest so these have been fairly
constant principles from the 1940s up to
the present day with you have they not
yes I mean you know like going to say
like anybody it's like making an excuse
you know I'm sure that along the way I
made mistakes and didn't handle things
correctly and and there's some very
difficult problems in life you know if
you're going to take these these things
seriously and one of the most difficult
problems comes about when you or in this
case me but but many many particularly
white middle-class people which is my
origin at least our advocates of
non-violence and then somebody who was
terribly terribly oppressed resorts to
some violence in an attempt to free
themselves now one of the things where
one reasons I sometimes hesitate to call
myself a pacifist although I'm a total
advocate of non-violent methods is it in
those situations sometimes the pastor's
say well we can't support the civil
rights movement because Robert Williams
who was a leader of the NAACP has said
that Negroes have a right to arm
themselves in self-defense or we can't
support the the Vietnamese so we can't
oppose America going over there is the
strongest military power in the world
and the richest most powerful country
and attacking the peasants we can't do
that because they're fighting back with
guns and whatnot so there are dilemmas
and I never know whether I've made
exactly the right decision at the right
time but the aim in my mind is to
maintain solidarity and emphasize the
right of the people to liberation and at
the same time to concentrate not on
whether you agree all the way with their
politics or their methods are not but on
in the case of Vietnam that there is no
excuse for the United States to be over
there bombing people uprooting villages
to dropping chemicals all the rest so
there's a rising you know I won't take
sides because was both a violent and I'm
also believe that and a lot of
Vietnamese with whom I've been in close
contact feel as to that the the price of
defensive military resistance
today with modern warfare and modern
weapons has become so great and we have
by now enough historical examples of the
fact that a united people employing
nonviolent means can overthrow the worst
dictator or the most cruel tyrant such
as happened in Iran where the people
were not nonviolent by choice but by
force of circumstances and whatever
problems persist there today and I think
there is some very bad problems there
nonetheless there was a period when the
people of Iran essentially without arms
decided they would not tolerate the
dictatorship of the Shia as supported by
the United States and they were able to
bring about his downfall it was only
after that then when they gained control
of the army and got arms and so forth
that you know that the violence can't
begin to began to come in so seriously
on their side Dave in the 1950s we all
experienced the horrors of the atom bomb
actually we had the graphic testimony of
Hiroshima to show its powerful
destructiveness to dis intensify your
commitment to the peace movement and to
banning the bomb was this a major impact
on you do you think the fact of atomic
weapons and the possibility of nuclear
holocaust well yes and I should by the
way just flash back and say the fact
that the United States dropped the bomb
on Hiroshima and Nagasaki at a time when
Japan was desperately suing for peace
confirmed at least part of our my and
other people's reasons for not
supporting the US military in world war
ii namely that we became not in
superficial cultural detail but but in
in some core some essence the united
states government became almost like the
german government in the sense that it
thought it had the right to wipe out
these people and as i say to wipe them
out at a time when japan was already
defeated and was suing for peace to lie
to the country by saying that it was
necessary to save American lives but to
do it in order to demonstrate that it
held the Doomsday weapons in it
and in that way it could dominate and
control the world and and create what
Henry Luce of Life magazine called the
American Century in which basically the
American Empire would replace the the
British Empire and the aspiring German
Empire and Americans would control the
world and basically become number one so
the bomb really initially confirmed your
drive towards the need for radical
social change in America you saw them
again
the sort of roots and the sort of
militaristic structure of the political
economy well the Internet yes right
right the desire to dominate the world
to make all of the world there as much
as well as possible safe for profit for
multinational corporations based
initially in America that that that led
that was the reason basically or one of
the main reasons that they dropped the
bomb and developed the hydrogen bomb and
tried to maintain nuclear dominance the
horror of nuclear weapons helped to
radicalize you and to make you a peace
activist well I can I'm one of the
people who can clearly remember being in
grade school and having atomic bomb
drills where we would all get down under
our desks or go out in the hall
assuming there was going to be an atomic
bomb dropped on our city and as if we
would be protected by hiding under the
desk from it I'm sure that made an
impression on me I also grew up during
the period of the Korean War and I
remember that quite clearly my own
radicalization I think happened during
the Vietnam War like so many other
people in my generation and really not
until the Vietnam War became a very
direct immediacy in my life that is that
I was drafted and knew there was a
fairly good chance I was going to be in
Vietnam within a few months that's when
I started turning around they when did
you first become active in opposing the
Vietnam War and what led you to this
well actually remember it at an Easter
anti bomb march of a coalition in New
York which was one of the largest held a
that time about 10,000 people some
people showed up with a sign saying us
out of Vietnam and at that time I mean I
opposed the u.s. being in Vietnam but I
hardly knew about it nobody did
and I always remember you know there was
this now well I get confused 62 years
but I think well 62 is the most apt to
be there was a very minor issue in
people's minds it was like they tried to
do with El Salvador you know we're just
sending down whatever we're advisory
advisors and so forth and they'll be out
of there soon and anyway there's a
danger of becoming sort of single issue
I remember the chairperson of that rally
that anti bomb rally objected to the
presence of these signs because it was
introducing an extraneous element and I
remember turned to him and saying but
fired they're opposing US military
adventure how can you say that they
don't belong in the anti bomb rally and
he said well then you know we all agree
that this is an anti bomb rally and they
shouldn't be introducing that because
some people might think that the United
States belongs there and so on well
that's sort of a personal incident I
guess but from then I I developed a
heightened interest in it but people
sometimes romanticize the 60s as if it
was just a decade in which everybody was
out in the streets all the time and it
was the thing to do and so forth I can
tell you that from that pit roll from
1961 that instant might have been 61
actually but from 1961 until 1966 at
least there were five very difficult
lonely years when there wasn't there
were no masses in the streets and when
anytime we went out we were subject to
being attacked by angry quote Patriots
veterans groups American Legionnaires
and all the rest and was only because a
lot of people and by the way this didn't
begin even there was because people had
been in the South in the civil rights
movement you know facing the police dogs
and the fire hoses and all arrests and
preparing a kind of attitude and
developing a kind of
regeneration of what I would consider
the best American spirit it was only
through years of that kind of thing that
eventually reached the point where as
many as a million people would protest
throughout the country in the same day
against the war
what are some of the lessons we can
learn from the 60s that are still useful
for us in terms of wanting to change
American society today well first of all
I would say that one has to learn that
these things do function in a seasonal
manner and that if people had not
opposed the Korean War that ken
mentioned at a time when there were no
huge rallies and and no mass movement
and if people hadn't gone into the South
and carried certain values and attitudes
and being willing willing to if
necessary in many cases actually
sacrificed their lives for it and if
people had said oh the whole country
supports the Vietnam War so I'm not
going to go out and get my head beaten
in or I'm not going to get my parents
angry at me or risk my job and so forth
if people hadn't done that in the non
glory days so to speak the wooden of the
movement wouldn't have developed the
extent that it would've secondly though
let me just ask you on that favor you
sort of gratified or happy when you see
the response of the public today to El
Salvador as testimony that all the
struggles of the 60s paid off that here
we have another military adventure going
on and in its early stages we were able
to mobilize a fairly large number of
people for demonstrations and a very
impressive public opinion polls against
intervention in El Salvador does that
sort of illustrate what you just said
that the struggles of the 60s weren't in
vain and it was the continuity of those
struggles that makes it more difficult
for America now to get a new military
adventures absolutely and I would add to
that that it also shows that the press
and the politicians and a lot of people
were promoting a false sense of the 70s
that a lot was going on in the 70s that
was very basic and then if
hadn't gone on probably the response to
the adventure in El Salvador in the
growing response which I anticipate is
going to get much much greater to the
Reagan budget cuts and emphasis of the
military and of American machismo I
don't think it would have happened but
if that's really one of the lessons of
the 60s I think is that at the beginning
there was what was called the new left
that is when the movement began to
develop in substance it all around
basically around 1965 and in that time
there was a lot of experimental activity
there was no no thought that there had
to be at one single correct way to
oppose the war that everybody had to
think the same politically but there was
a great diversity and when we held
teach-ins if somebody asked a question
which said you know something like well
isn't it true that the American advisors
were over there only helping the
Vietnamese people in trying to introduce
democracy to the country instead of well
they'd get a serious answer and all
kinds of questions were discussed and
analyzed in a thoughtful way there was
no pressure for kind of more opinion
that everybody had to think the same
later it got to the point although this
was not typical of the masses and the
movements but there were too many
meetings when if somebody expressed a
point of view which deviate a little bit
from the organizers of the meeting they
would be ridiculed or condemned or
called the enemy or pigs or something
which is the worst traits of the old
left that a new left initially initially
had gotten rid of and what has been your
experience these are the people's
responsiveness to your positions on El
Salvador well I agree with xx Dave said
totally I can remember Becky even in the
mid 60s being in anti-war demonstrations
in Colorado of five or six or ten people
it took years and years of building
during the Vietnam War to to get the
kind of major opposition that eventually
I think forced the u.s. out of its
involvement in Vietnam it's taken us
just a matter of months to
organized opposition to u.s. involvement
in El Salvador defined quite a response
among the population that's right I
think one of the things that that we
have going for us this time is a pretty
broad understanding among the American
public about how the u.s. is is
maintaining an empire of what the US has
real motives are the protection of our
raw materials our resources the things
that that we've come to expect the rest
of the world to supply us that wasn't
true in the 60s I think one of the real
contributions of the new left was to to
give people a kind of analysis of of how
the American Empire really worked and
people understand that now and they
accept that I think something else that
people understand now that they weren't
quite as willing to accept them was that
in order to protect this multinational
Empire we have to have military
alliances with dictators and military
hunters of the repressive sort and I
think Reagan very cynically and brutally
in his complete rejection of Carter's
civil rights human sorry human rights
policy has made it clear that the price
of this American foreign policy is the
support of military dictators and I
think the people aren't willing to
accept let me just flash back for a
minute you asked at the beginning about
World War two one of the reasons that a
lot of people did not support the
Americans in American government in
world war two was for that very same
phenomenon that although eventually
after first playing footsie with Hitler
and contributing to his rise they
apparently turned against fascism but
their allies and the governments that
they supported all over the world were
again the fascist totalitarian
governments and it was just hitler was
singled out as being the one that they
were going to get rid of Dave let's move
on out of the second lesson sixties you
could become so impatient and so upset
over what the United States was doing in
Vietnam not only to the Vietnamese but
the 200 GIS were coming home in canvas
bags every week you know you could
become so horrified
by this that you build up a certain kind
of impatience in a head of steam and you
could go out into the streets with
hostility and not reaching out to people
not understanding and the teaching was
one example but not understanding that
we're all conditioned by this society
and we all have certain attitudes and
beliefs one of them being that the
United States is is the only democratic
good Society in the world or the best at
least and then when it goes abroad it's
it's you know doing good things and so
you could go out with a chip on your
shoulder toward the people who disagreed
with you and I think that with nuclear
the danger of nuclear war you know
really creating the final solution to
the world's problems and you know in
quotes in terms of the ultimate
Holocaust sometimes people or people
just just being so embittered by what's
happening to their jobs by runaway
plants and all the rest that it's
possible to become rather narrow in in
one's attitudes in the end to carry a
kind of hatred and anger into things now
anger can be helpful but hatred can't I
think to lead lead to not realizing that
we're all in this you know confused and
fumbling and trying to find our way and
sort things out and it's not where a
person is today he might be in uniform
today suppressing you but he may also
have a lot of reservations and
uncertainties and that it never pays to
think which happened in the late 60s
that that guy is somehow a pig but to
think that he also was instead that he
also was a victim and a potential ally
and to try to recruit and work with him
and even though you must defy him at
certain points or disobey his orders
that nonetheless you reach out to him as
a human being and that of course is one
half at least or one part of the essence
of non-violence is a related lesson from
the 60s that things like the Vietnam War
shouldn't be seen in isolation as a
single issue right there was a lot of
radicals saw the war or not really
radicals but a lot of protesters saw the
war is an
saluté evil when it was over there for
the problems would be solved and over
whereas I think in your perspective you
see the or the war as expressive of the
sort of root causes and a situation in
American society that needs to be
addressed so with that being a lesson of
the 60s that one can have single issue
politics be it anti nuclear energy or
anti-war policies but one has to see how
these are related to the whole systemic
situation the poet Kenneth Patchen
speaking of the anti-war movement of his
day once said the trouble is they want
to get rid of war without getting rid of
the causes of war but it's not only that
when 44% of the people born in Latin
America children die before the age of
five from causes attributable to poverty
basically into American capital control
of the of the country they're just as
dead as if they'd been killed in a war
and you have to be just as concerned for
them as you would for a civilian who was
bombed to death so in terms of the
lessons of the 60s we saw that the
anti-war movement was there that took
place that I was effective not only is
stopping the Vietnam war but building up
the consensus and a basis to stop later
imperialist interventions but we saw
that some radicals tended to be a bit
too fanatic or too dogmatic and not
really to address the population as
allies in the project of social change
and we saw that a lot of people focused
too much on one issue politics thinking
that the Vietnam War in itself was the
evil of American society when when once
it went away the problems would be
solved would you like to comment on that
a bit yeah I'd like Martha I'd like to
give an example for example the anti-war
movement grew not just anti-vietnam war
movement out of the anti Barr moment but
out of the experience in the south of
civil the civil rights struggle and they
came a time I'll just condense this but
became a time in late 1966 and early 912
particularly late 1966 when large
numbers of people were getting out in
the end
I wore a movement and and we were
beginning to develop a vigorous movement
and we had always had strong black
participation and I'm speaking of the
actions in particularly mobilization
coming to end the war and I came into a
continuation committee meeting once and
it was in New York about a hundred
people and our treasurer proposed that
we stop talking so much about black
needs and black problems and having so
many black speakers because he said you
know that's just adding a second issue
and some people really don't go with
that and we have a chance to stop the
war if we get the masses of the people
with us simultaneously enough a very in
many ways and a good man he resigned
because he felt we were making a mistake
to emphasize black problems at the same
time with the war simultaneously with
that I along with a number of other
people had been trying for years to get
Martin Luther King to come out against
the war he was an advocate of
non-violence a leader of nonviolent
movements and in the civil rights
struggle and he had what he had been
wishy-washy on the issue and had never
taken part in the demonstration against
the war in Vietnam and when the point
arrived when King finally with a lot of
pressure including from less well-known
people less favoured by the media likes
Nick the Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee and other black leaders had
really taken the lead in speaking out
against the war and finally Martin
Luther King decided that he would take
part in our demonstration in April of
1967 we went to a fundraising party for
King's organization the Southern
Christian Leadership Conference and some
of his funders came up to him and said
if you march in that demonstration
Martin we are withdrawing our funds and
as a background for that only what they
thought but what had been going on in
the several years that we'd been talking
with King and trying to persuade him to
take a strong stand people had said well
you know the issue of civil rights is
called enough but if you come out
against the war - then they will accuse
you of being unpatriotic and not
supporting your country and so it was
the best of intentions he just like on
the other end some anti-war people to
want to keep quiet about civil rights he
didn't want to but he did keep quiet
about the war
well I think that King who was a
honorable moral person reached the point
where he could be silent no longer and
he took part and he understood I think
Howard our society had been co-opted by
the press and by the government
beginning with John F Kennedy and he
linked not only war and race but also
economics and he began to organize the
Poor People's Campaign which is going to
bring all of these issues together all
oppressed people in the country were
going to come together American Indians
and blacks and poor whites and you know
people suffering from the war and so
forth and I believe that when he did
that and because he did have the
charisma and the power and had been
built up by the media because they
thought they could use him at that point
that there was the potential of a united
movement that really would have turned
the country around or done much more
than was accomplished and and one year
after he appeared in our April 4th 1967
March or April actions April 7th then
one year later in less three days he was
dead because he United those things I
think that sure I'd offer that as a kind
of condensed summary not only of the
problems the temptations to isolate one
issue but also the potential power when
they are all brought together and the
realization of people very high in this
country of how they could be United and
that they had to get rid of King for
that reason well I think one of the
other things that really prevented the
rise of that kind of unifying of the
issues and unifying of people during
that left was the question of
sectarianism the tendency in the both in
the American left and I
also unfortunately in the American peace
movement to fractionalize into sectarian
groups that spend their time battling
with each other and I've also been a
little distressed to see that kind of
phenomena beginning to rise again in
people who are working against the draft
who are working against us involvement
in El Salvador the Reagan budget cuts
what she was a really length you have to
work together and addressing these
problems yeah and I'd like to ask Dave
what kinds of things he thinks can be
done to to unify people so that we don't
split up again into wrangling sectarian
groups
sort of movement building strategy
that's one thing about the 60s finally
they evolved what was called here
movement right which encompassed a
variety of these groups well I think
that first of all you do have to
establish the linkages to understand
that the way beginning with the Roman
Empire at least that's where I first
learned that you know that the rule was
divided and rule and that if we divide
ourselves then we're doing the systems
work for it
secondly I think we do have to adopt the
spirit of solidarity in diversity and to
think well you see it comes back to the
idea that there's that like one path to
truth or one Road to revolution or one
Vanguard group which is usually my group
of course you know who I am that that
has the answer to learn that in nature
there isn't one flower that is the most
beautiful or one tree that's the most
magnificent or one river or anything it
it's all contributes to the total the
total organism really and that to build
a new society we have to start with the
assumption of multiplicity and diversity
but at the same time establishes the
links and established the the the
Solidarity so instead of going into a
coalition and trying to caucus I mean
the caucuses can be fine if they're open
and not don't try
dominate but the set of Coxon going in
and trying to get everybody to think
like I think or everybody to take the
action that I feel like taking the one
has to maintain this this openness and
to know that real science operates by
trial and error and experiment rather
than telling some person you know from
on high or from science what the truth
is and so you've got to allow people to
try different things and you've got a by
process of trial and error and by many
people doing different things build kind
of a United strength there's a whole
emphasis which there really isn't time
to go into but a kind of a decentralized
well I would say interesting enough the
women's movement in a way where they've
stressed that the personal is the
political you know that reduces things
to human scale in a militant way by
reducing it doesn't mean it makes them
less real or less valuable makes them
more real and more valuable and the
anti-nuclear movement with its
decentralized emphasis where people take
care of business where they are on the
other hand if I just say one more word
on it Paul Goodman who said something
very important I think that people at
the most vital areas of their life must
live in face-to-face communities and
face-to-face relationships where they
are accountable and other people are
accountable he said you also have to be
come both more local and more global at
the same time and when people say to me
as they're beginning to do again as they
did in the late 60s which do you favor
local action or national action I always
say well that's like asked me which I
favor breathing in or breathing out if
you don't do both you're in trouble if
you don't have national demonstrations
where people can get a sense of the
strength and the massiveness of the
movement and they're not just some Kooks
as locally people will try to convince
them I mean you know you lose something
but if on the other hand you have just
event after event in Washington or some
other place and people aren't doing the
hard nitty gritty grassroots daily work
of transforming their lives
transforming their neighborhood and
transforming everything from their love
relationships to their work
relationships to the community growth
development all all arrests if they're
not doing that why the national
demonstrations become more and more
narrow and more and more futile so it's
almost as important almost as important
as the issues that we're working on are
they're preserving that kind of politics
of openness that kind of experimentalism
and that kind of flexibility okay and
working I think simultaneously see that
another one of these things like are you
for local and nationalists
do you think that first you must change
people or change the society change the
institution's you can't change the
institution's except by changing the
people but you can't change the people
if you're changing themselves in a
vacuum without relationship to the daily
institutions they've got it's got to go
on simultaneously and you told me
earlier this week in a conversation that
you thought was exemplary about Dave
Dellinger as a longtime movement
activist was his openness his
flexibility and his ability to build
bridges between different their groups
yeah and the other thing I'd add it's
just a good dose of common sense of
being able to look at a situation and
and understand what's going on in a very
simple clear way
well could I want to interrupt because I
get a little nervous about this I think
that's so terribly important is not to
make heroes of people because like I am
older and therefore been involved longer
but I can tell you that in 1965 when the
new left began to flower I learned more
from the new left from I don't know a
new I'd be competitive out I learned as
much from the new left as the new left
learn from me and one of the things that
has to happen is that we have to break
down the ageism young people every
generation comes with new insights or
insights that we've forgotten on the
other hand people who have been around
longer and experienced certain things
have certain understandings and insights
which are also part of the picture so we
must all of a simultaneously both teach
and learn what are some of the interests
well I would like you to continue are
some of the bridges the
should be built some of the links
between different movements well it one
of the advantages that we have now again
compared to the 60s is the broader range
of people were working with when we're
talking about us opposition to to
involvement in El Salvador for instance
now we're talking about labor unions
being really involved we're talking
about a whole large veterans movement in
the 60s there were no veterans who were
on our side or very few well there were
some were generated out of the war that
there were at the beginning or very few
sure and so we're just working with a
whole broader range of people now and
that calls for I think a lot more
sensitivity a lot more understanding of
how issues are interrelated and a lot
more willingness to be open and to
listen to people who are different than
you and to learn from them are you
encouraged by some of the linkages that
you've seen in recent years in the
anti-nuclear movement or in the movement
against El Salvador etc yes there's a
long way still to go it's it's not easy
you know it's like the neatest trick of
the decade to be able to continue
focusing on your own oppression and
that's one again one of the things the
women's movement taught us that you you
can't say to any group or to yourself
well this oppression can wait while we
fight against that one you've got to be
again that's what openness and honesty
means is not accepting oppression for
yourself or anybody else but it's the
neatest trick of the decade if we can
maintain that and at the same time
maintain United actions and you know
keep the two things happening together
and it's it's not I think the movement
is in that direction more and more
people realize that that everything is
linked it's all sort of a matter of a
common economic economy and common
assumptions and attitudes that cause the
problems in whatever area of life but
although more and more people realize
that there are still breakdowns
occurring you know where
where suddenly people at one racer are
excoriated in an argument like in the el
salvador question that really where race
is not the issue or where women are made
once again to feel inferior and/or step
back a little bit and let we men who you
know make a better appearance on
television or or you know it's like the
old Martin Luther King civil rights
anti-war thing all over again so that
does does crop up it has to has to be
tackled there's a lot of commentators
and people who look at America today saw
the 1970s is sort of an apathetic
passive quiescent decade and then saw
this culminated with a victory of the
new right and reaganism in 1980 with
Reagan claiming he has a mandate for his
problems he share this view of the 1970s
in American society today how do you
perceive this well first of all is see I
think that the spirit with which one
does something is as important as the
goals for which one spirit and the means
as the goals for which one is working
and I think that toward the end of the
60s because it was an emergency period
and because people did suffer a lot and
people were impatient there was a kind
of a harshness and the shrillness and a
lot of loss of perspective that tended
to creep in and a lot of what has been
derided as narcissism and going off in a
corner and meditating and forgetting the
world I think was a very important
reaching out for deeper roots and
understandings and getting you know the
phrase used to be about getting your
head clear or getting here your values
in order now to the extent that those
tendencies those needs were prostituted
by authoritarian gurus or by
money-making charlatans or you know
people who hadn't you know like they say
of some therapists that they have a need
for disciples so they'll keep you as a
patient as long as they can to the
extent that that happened obviously it
was deplorable and it did happen but in
the same way
I wasn't about to give up politics
because the developed a cult of
personality in politics and because a
lot of left groups and even a country
like the Soviet Union developed some
very repressive means of dealing with
people so I didn't say well there's no
hope we will just go with what we've got
which is capitalist cynicism and and so
forth and in the same way I think that
it was wrong to throw out the whole
search for some kind of sometimes these
words not popular but some kind of pure
approach to life and less egocentric
approach and you know to get rid of the
ego in the manner that the Buddhist
advocated and guess any true religion
does I'm not a don't think that either
should be abandoned because sometimes it
was taken advantage of by charlatans or
by people who just didn't understand
fully so I see the 70s as a very
important period of preparing the way
for what I hope will be a very strong
militant insistent political movement
which at the same time does maintain
some long old fashioned words but the
spirit of love and cooperation and
sensitivity to other people which will
unite unite these letters in a way that
we didn't we haven't always always done
in the past do you think that the new
right really has a mandate for their
programs that go against everything that
you just said this anti VRA
anti-abortion anti social change anti
just about even television or do you
think that this is just a sort of
marginal no you see even after as many
as a million people protested the war in
the last last year's when when an
overwhelming majority the country
opposed it they still tried to talk
about the silent majority or the middle
American majority who supported the war
now they speak about the moral majority
well by now I think that's been exposed
quite a bit but when Reagan claims a
mandate for views which are
horrendous for most people not as they
are described in certain generalized
ways you know where you know when he
speaks about America getting strong
again and you think of the you know the
early colonists who stood behind a tree
with a musket to fight off the Redcoats
you know in a world where that's not
true but in fact only 26% of the
eligible electorate voted for Ronald
Reagan or slightly less than 26% I think
and of those many many people voted for
change not for the kind of repressive
policies that are coming in because they
didn't have jobs because they were
getting destroyed by inflation or
because they were worried about the
danger of war and the hypocrisy of the
proceeding and as well as the
inefficiency and ineffectiveness of the
preceding administration so actually I
think that a long said I don't want to
oversimplify anything many people are
unhappy alienated from the existing
institutions ten even tending to get
discouraged not knowing what to do about
it but I think that at the same time
there is the potential amongst those
people for embracing new ideas and new
methods and for understanding that the
society is so sick and so out of whack
that we have to try a lot of new things
and as Reagan's methods obviously fail I
think that there's hope that people will
begin to extend into larger
relationships the relationships that
they've developed in in smaller groups
now you know in their in their family
well you know a love relationships in
communes and little little organizations
and and and groups so you see the
possibility for another mass movement
for social change in American society
that could lead to a revitalized our
left yes the only thing I get slightly
afraid of the word mass I think it can
be massive and large and they
densive but I think that if it if it
only operates as a mass then you know
this quality which the 70s helped
develop in the country and in the
movement and there's a danger of its
being lost thankfully as a final
question what is I kept you going for
these are for decades one of your
deepest hopes or what values have you
been striving to realize or what faith
has just kept you going day to day and
all these different movements and
struggles well I could say a lot of
things probably what am I was
interesting I was with somebody about 10
years older than I was and he was asked
that question and he said oh don't you
get discouraged I brought don't you act
differently he says what can you think
of any better way to live in other words
living relating to people in a positive
way and trying to fight for those values
but I could also say that I think that
one of the luckiest things that happened
to me was very painful and that was when
I spent three years in a federal
penitentiary because I came in touch
with the prime victims of society and I
saw you know in Plato's phrase I saw a
society writ large in that because the
kid gloves were off and you saw you know
not only you got to know intimately the
lives of the people but you saw how the
society treated them when they resisted
and where people didn't see how they
what would happen to them as they would
be brutalized and I think from that time
on I've learned that even though you
must everybody must try to achieve a
certain amount of solitude and privacy
and quiet and not just be constantly on
the barricades
you know reflectiveness and so with that
perspective closeness with nature at the
same time you cannot live substantially
what I'll call an upper class life in
isolation from the victims of society
and maintain a proper perspective and
partly beginning with the friendships I
made in jail you know I guess I've been
constantly in touch with black people
whose anger gets communicated and whose
sufferings and with American Indians and
Mexicans and poor whites and all the
rest and I think that if one is not
coming to academic or to kind of the way
a certain political sex that Ken refers
to getting lost in what Lenin says Oh
mark says or or if you're more religious
and what some religious figure said
Connie
yes but exactly Gandhi is a beautiful
example of that you know where it can
lead people astray if you are in touch
with the people who are living working
and suffering and you're not taking the
easy way out of living in isolation from
them they drive you you're going you
know you can't say oh I'm tired of all
this now I don't feel like demonstrating
today if you are in touch you know with
young black children growing up in the
ghetto of Brooklyn which is what my own
life experience at this point well you
have traveled to Vietnam to Cuba to Iran
and seeing some of these situations of
oppression and struggle have you not has
that also been part of this touching to
people and experiencing their needs and
struggles that's right I mean I often
think of what Susan Sontag said when she
visited Hanoi and North Vietnam during
the war and walked through the territory
at first she was very disappointed in
them because she felt pity for them and
they didn't seem to feel any pity for
themselves and secondly because they
used words like imperialism and
colonialism and capitalism and she'd
only heard those words used in a
rhetorical sense and kind of with it
with a kind of hostility but as she
actually been there for a while she
realized two things one that when they
spoke of imperialism and colonialism
they were speaking from their life
experience and secondly that they they
were better off than the than the people
in her home in America even as they were
dying and suffering all the things which
had to be stopped but because they knew
at that point what they were fighting
for and they were fighting for values
which were stronger than than the
individual and I think that when one
goes when at least when I could have
gone to third world country sometimes I
disagree with there
politics are their tactics on a
particular thing but one gets a sense of
this great upsurge of life you know of
people who are determined no longer to -
well to be the patsies in a situation
when the United States with four percent
of the world's population speaks of its
right to consume 40 percent of the
world's resources as the Reagan caspar
weinberger in yesterday was quoted in
the paper and just a typical vote of the
importance of the United States
preserving access to its strategic
resources in the Persian Gulf as if the
the world was just an oyster bed to the
United States to feed upon well Dave
Dellinger Ken carpenter thank you very
much for coming and for the conversation
today and thank you both for being
tonight thank you very much